before we start anything this is the and
this works for audio listeners too okay
but this is the way
this is the funniest sequence on tick
tock
and
this will work perfect for audio
listeners you just need to know the
context this is one of those tick tock
streams
where it's like disturb me at my job
okay you've seen those right nope what
no i haven't okay so there's
this is an evolution of the disturb my
sleep racket okay so i know that is
you are a liar actress
i mean i can guess
yeah what would you guess people stream
themselves sleeping and if you donate
enough you can [ __ ] up their sleep yeah
so people set up crazy things in the
room to make noise while they pretend to
sleep the thing is they're never
actually sleeping got it it's the
easiest and smartest way to stream so an
evolution of that is disturb me at my
job love it and people pretend to be
working and then they have a sign up of
what you can donate to bother them and
they'll just kind of
you know
pretend to be disturbed by what you're
doing it looks like a live infomercial
or something so i came across this guy
last night what do you mean by that
let it rip
[Music]
[Music]
hahaha
oh
is that real or
i don't think he can actually hear it
okay it's just a chat
just going crazy just
oh man oh my god
so someone spent like 40 bucks on yeah
dude
[Laughter]
let's just scrum it tick tock play it
again and this is all i heard the first
just
[Laughter]
[Music]
what is that problem it's a good dude
busting it
damn dude i don't know why that fart
like just so repetitive
killed me so bad
the greatest part is i just screen
recorded it and i'm like weeping as i'm
recording because i'm like there's no
way
i just happened to catch
the moment
where someone spent 40 dollars
on farts it was just
that was a weirdly good impression
oh my god yeah man that's what this
podcast is for we talk about intelligent
stuff on this podcast yeah man yeah
i was like i told you i told you when i
like [ __ ] up the live stream of justin
bieber on new year's eve right
yeah yeah i think so
i want to let you tell it but
you know the scream right
no i don't know i don't know there's a
dude
the backstory was he had supposedly just
gotten out of jail okay
and he was having sex with cream pie
patty
actually i don't think he actually just
went out to jail cream pie patty
are you are you [ __ ] with me no are
you just inventing things no that's like
a just for me to be like i don't know
what that is no it's like a old school
porn star i think okay can you google
that yeah
[Laughter]
yeah
[Laughter]
you guys did not hear that
actually oh
just pictures of cream pies
like the actual pie
uh maybe you know i don't that's correct
i don't think we can i wanna i swear
that's her patty with a y maybe yeah no
let's not do that that i think that's
technically no sexual harassment if it
was a known thing no but making luke
look up porn in front of people right
now is technically sexual harassment
well we are in space so the laws don't
apply yeah
no no no
you don't have to collect that go to
images i'm kidding okay i'm kidding okay
so cream pie patty let's just let's
assume they're a real person i swear
that's like the watermark in the video
whale folks
noel was wrong again
but anyway it's this dude who just
he hits it a couple times and now i'm
guessing cream pie patty's
specialty yeah
is too is making out is making out right
kissing yeah
yeah right she makes a real good cream
pie yeah
[Laughter]
yeah she's actually just a very famous
uh food network person
and he was having sex with her yeah
and she just let him hit
live on tv
she was like this is my last episode i
[ __ ] i'm done with these people
yeah they've they've kept my show down
for years yeah they've not supported me
all through this journey
babe get out here and she just opened up
the back of her apron
and she was like let's show him how we
make love
no he's
she's like bent over just like with her
head like on the bed like looking up and
smiling at him
the dude just
gets like a good like motion to it and
he just goes
that's just the whole thing
and he's just shivering in her so this
is like okay it says like a a first nut
in years yeah type deal then he lets it
out and then then she just like starts
like rubbing his thigh and she's bent
over and she's like oh
oh look at you
big ol [ __ ]
pickled [ __ ]
yeah
nice load yeah
nice load
so yeah anyway justin bieber you [ __ ]
up the live stream yeah it was new
year's eve i think i've told the story
before but it was so [ __ ] funny man
it was new year's eve and uh this is
like
two years ago now 2020. yeah and
um justin bieber did a like a live
stream
right it was like in during kovid's you
can't have like concerts so he did a
live stream yeah we we found someone
that was restreaming it on twitch but
they had their own like emotes oh nice
and like sound effects when you bought
when you donated yeah so
at every single crescendo of justin
bieber's most popular hits
we would play we would donate like the
biggest one and it would play turned
down for what
so if you're like is it too late now to
turn down for once
every time
the chat was so [ __ ] mad dude the
whole chat was like
who is doing that stop playing turn down
for what guys stop please we just want
to watch justin bieber oh my god it was
so [ __ ] funny man i'd be comatose
i would be [ __ ] deceased
that's too good oh god that yeah good on
you yeah
i can't get the
this is almost better
yeah try to try to make the noise
[Music]
you